[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a este programa
especial de cultura en france 24 desde
el festival de la música del pacífico
petronio álvarez
[Música]
la ciudad de cali en colombia se
transforma durante unos días en el
corazón del pacífico' para acoger al
festival afro más importante de
latinoamérica en sus principios era una
competición de agrupaciones musicales de
la costa pacífica de colombia pero poco
a poco se acabó convirtiendo en una
ventana que muestra al mundo la
gastronomía la música y las artesanías
de la cultura afrodescendiente
un espacio gratuito para el público y
que los artistas valoran mucho por
visibilizar la riqueza y la residencia
de una de las zonas más maltratadas del
país es lo que nos contó la cantante en
ella góngora la cuenta y en el
departamento del cauca al suroccidente
de colombia y con los años se convirtió
en una de las embajadoras más poderosas
de la música tradicional del pacífico'
la escuchamos
[Música]
ni a color a muchas gracias por
compartir este momento con nosotros en
324 estamos acá en el personal del
teatro ya que es un musical de la música
del pacífico pero también es una muestra
de gastronomía de artesanía de moda es
una muestra de todos los sabores de esta
región y eso es importante para usted
este tipo de evento que muestra toda la
amplitud de su región es muy importante
para nosotros el pacífico colombiano es
una región diversa
rica en todos sentidos y con una riqueza
natural una regla biodiversidad la que
su gente con un capital humano
natural
y ecológico en ahora sí y ha sido una
región absolutamente
invisibilizada históricamente
entonces espacios como el festival de
música sirven para reivindicar
para visibilizar pero también para mover
no sólo la economía del pacífico sino
también todos esos para proyectar esa
cultura a nivel nacional a nivel
internacional creo que el festival es un
acto incluso
resistencia que que somos una región que
está viva
pese a las dificultades
pese al flagelo de la guerra es una
región que sigue demostrando su potencia
su potencial sus valores y usted con su
obra con su arte con su música se dedica
a tejer puentes entre el pacífico
colombiano y otros otros estilos de
múltiple a otros géneros otros
transacciones otros países eso desde el
principio eso fue el objetivo para usted
yo creo que ha sido importante
el poder llevar la música al mundo
porque la música ha perdido para
nosotros no solamente como muro de
contención y como una medicina de tanta
los conflictos sino que ha servido para
nosotros
significar la vida en el pacífico y
mostrarse
lo que nos inspira que es el pacífico
como estos gente como se vive que hay en
el pacific ha servido para sanar el
dolor y ha servido también para
empoderarnos como hombres y mujeres que
a pesar de haber tenido o haber hecho
parte de un historial triste de
herederos de hombres y mujeres que
fueron esclavizados a través de la
música se reivindicó y se visitó aviones
sin claridad nuestras mujeres de
nuestros hogares
danzaron cantaron a pesar de los azotes
del dolor de la humillación nunca
dejaron de cantar nunca dejaron de alzar
su voz entonces creo que la música como
un elemento de resistencia ha servido
para resignificar
muchísimas cosas dentro y fuera de sí
como usted se siente
hacer ahora hoy en día una de las
figuras más importantes del pacífico
colombiano al internacional me siento
muy feliz me siento
honrada y orgullosa porque
yo vengo de una familia de cantoras y mi
mamá y mi abuela desde muy pequeña me
inculcaron a mí valores y valores muy
importantes como reconocer al otro desde
su humanidad
pero sobre todo sentir orgullo por por
lo que yo represento de dónde vengo de
mi raíz
de estas personas que me antecedieron
sentirme orgullosa de lo que soy como
mujer negra de mi estética
y sentirte orgullosa de mis raíces
africanas como mujeres negras y mujeres
colombianas
no es fácil
[Aplausos]
el artista
fácil ser una estructura representativa
porque te encuentras con muchas barreras
si muchas barreras porque la poca
siempre luchar el doble entre pero creo
que lo importante es que yo llevo esa
pases me quite ese no
y me sembraron y reconozco que como
mujeres tenemos derechos tenemos
capacidades y que a partir de lo que
sabemos de lo que aprendemos podemos
llegar a conquistar el mundo
y a través de esta conquista llevar
mucho buenas
[Música]
el petróleo respiraba y se mueve a ritmo
de la marín da un instrumento con raíces
africanas muy arraigado esta región
tanto en el escenario durante los
conciertos como en los espacios de
artesanías es un instrumento clave en
este festival ado puso de la fundación
katanga nos explicó por qué es tan
importante en la cultura del recinto
bueno la marimba
es el instrumento que ha exorcizado todo
es todo ese dolor de los negros
esclavizados y llegaron a casas
en la marimba que la permitió a la gente
recordar y traer memoria de sudáfrica
fábrica materna
y que además que alrededor de la marimba
se unía a toda la comunidad o sea que la
marimba si es el instrumento y con el
pacífico declarado patrimonio inmaterial
de por la unesco así que bueno ahora es
un símbolo
momentos que hay que seguir cuidando y
amando porque además de que produce un
sonido hermoso
nos pone las
cosas
básicas
veamos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y tras dos años de pandemia el petróleo
volvió por fin a su formato original y
con él volvió la alegría del público que
se puede sentir en cada rincón además en
esta edición número 26 la gran novedad
es que por primera vez de su historia el
festival tiene a una nación invitada
brasil a la celebración de un legado
cultural y étnico común y que va más
allá de la frontera terrestre que
comparten
[Música]
brasil es llamada la roma negra o sea la
población con mayor cantidad de
afrodescendientes cali en la segunda
ciudad en américa latina con mayor
cantidad de afrodescendientes eso ya no
se identifica no se identifica la
gastronomía no se identifica la cultura
allá se habla your back is ni get
entonces ya hay una hermandad yo creo
que es un momento de fortalecimiento de
sus lazos fraternos entre colombia y
brasil y también una gran oportunidad
para conocernos más somos países muy
similares tenemos una frontera
estratégica masónica yo siempre digo que
la amazonía nos une pero hay que
acercarnos más a través de la cultura y
de la educación yo creo que ese es el
camino
[Música]
el petróleo se vive como una experiencia
global de la riqueza cultural del
pacífico que se abre al mundo para
mostrar sus saberes ancestrales es un
territorio que vibra por su música pero
también por su sabor es un arte
culinario tiene honores que nos da la
mejor chef del mundo exaltó en un
conversatorio aquí en el espacio de
cocina del evento ella nos junto porque
es importante de preservar esta
gastronomía del pacífico como un
patrimonio vivo
la cocina del pacífico por supuesto
tiene su memoria era en africano pero
áfrica dentro de un territorio de selva
de selva tropical y eso la hace distinta
y cerca al mar pacífico
entonces como los ecosistemas influye
por supuesto que se ha nutrido
productos de estos ecosistemas
es una cocina
colorida alegre
de ingredientes
como productos de mar e ingredientes de
selva pero sobre todo siempre está
alojada y siempre está condimentada con
las hierbas
de azotea que son las hierbas que se
siembran no solamente para usos
medicinales o para usos
mágico espirituales sino también son
condimentarias y son junto a la leche de
coco las que le imprimen esa fuerza y
ese sabor inigualable
así se termina esta especial sobre el
festival de música del pacífico petronio
álvarez pueden encontrar este programa y
muchos más entre los 24 y france24
puntocom muchas gracias por su confianza
[Música]